hey I need to present to you evidence
from something I am calling soup gate
after the Tuesday show I was later on in
the day just reviewing clips and I often
like to take a look at how is the
lighting how were all the graphical
elements and I noticed that there was
something very bizarre on my face as I
was watching the clips and at after
noticing that i went to the mirror that
was closest to where i was at the time
and realized that i had a big red dot on
my chin and I leaned in and got very
very close to the mirror and realized
that some of my beet soup known as
borscht that I had had earlier that day
for lunch apparently had splashed onto
my face and I did the entire show with
about a half inch red dot of dried
borscht on my face and what was stunning
and I'm showing you some of the pictures
here with sort of successively greater
zooms on what it was that was on my face
there i texted Pat and I asked them hey
I have this I had this thing on my face
the entire time and what did you say Pat
that you mentioned it but you thought it
was a pimple so you didn't want to
offend me by bringing it up well I
noticed something there it was very very
subtle but yeah I didn't want to mention
it because I didn't know if it was a
scratch or blemish or something and of
course we were talking during
pre-production but I was you know
looking directly into your eyes and I
didn't want to offend you in any way by
staring directly at it it's sort of like
that scene in one of the I think Austin
Powers movies where Fred Savage plays a
guy with a huge mole and everybody's
trying to look away from it that's
effectively what I think was going on it
crossed my mind that this was sort of
like a passive-aggressive thing from Pat
because since Pat vegan that day on the
show I had put up a picture of a corned
beef sandwich that I had at Michael's
delhi a Jewish style deli in brookline
massachusetts and I it occurred to me
Pat that maybe you were taking it out on
me by allowing me to do the entire show
with borscht on my face oh yeah totally
you figured it out there I mean I think
it just clearly we have to get some hair
and makeup people on the show
yeah or at least I need to look in the
mirror before I sit down in front of the
camera so soup gate fortunately has not
taken down the show so far and I hope
we'll be able to persevere